the format you want to know when you're
compounding continuously that's the key
phrase when you see compounding
continuously that tells you to use this
perform eula so the P stands for the
principle that's what you start with
that's the initial amount and then a
that's your natural base e 2.71 you can
find that on your calculator and then
the R is the interest rate okay and you
want to convert that to a decimal by
moving the decimal point two places to
the left and then T is the time and you
want to make sure you see that's in
years so let's go through an example say
for example you have two thousand
dollars and the interest rate of seven
percent and you're compounding
continuously that's the key phrase to
use the PERT formula and it says you
know how long is going to take for you
to triple your money right okay now I
did another video talking about time to
double and what I wanted to illustrate
in this video is is that okay we're
going to start with our formula a equals
PE to the RT the $2,000 is really not
that important when you're just trying
to figure out the time to triple what's
more important is the interest rate okay
but you can see like P is what you're
starting with you want to end up with
three times P right so triple right and
then you can see the interest rate is a
seven percent so that's point zero seven
and we're trying to solve for the time
time to triple okay so what we can do
here is if you divide both sides by P
see how that's cancelling out so you're
really just getting three equals e to
the point zero seventy so it didn't
really matter if it was two thousand
you're starting with or ten thousand or
five dollars it doesn't really matter
the time to triple is going to be the
same it's affected by the interest rate
so now what we're doing is you know
we're working from the outside in
gradually trying to get this T by itself
but you can see it's up there in the
exponent exponent position okay it's an
exponential function so what we want to
do is we want to do the inverse okay
just like when you're squaring you know
you square root or if you're multiplying
you divide or you add or subtract here
if you're exponentiating right you want
to do the opposite you want to take the
logarithm now we're going to take the
natural log okay Ln write a both sides
of the equation to keep it balanced but
this is really like log base E so they
won't write it but it's understood to be
base E and I sometimes will write it in
there just so I can recognize the fact
that this is log base E this is an
exponential function base e those are
inverses and they undo or cancel one
the route and so now we're down to
natural log of three equals zero point
zero seven times T and we're just going
to divide both sides by 0.7 to get that
time by itself so let's go to the
calculator let's find out what this came
out to it's natural log of 3 ok / 0
points:0 seven and we're coming out to
fifteen point seven years okay so
fifteen point seven years you could
maybe round this almost 16 years and
that's the solution so I hope this
helped me to understand how to work with
compound interest and compounding
continuously in the PERT formula
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel
mario's math tutoring and I look forward
to seeing the future videos I'll talk to
you soon